hello boys gina linetti the human form
of the 100 emoji i'm gina linetti and i
approve this message
i love you
pizzazz is who i am amateur always say
your insults to someone's face no paper
trail i'm wired to thrive on dysfunction
i was thinking how i would make the
perfect american president based upon my
skill set
dance ability and bloodlust she's over
there dazzling some psychologists all
men are at least 30 attracted to me my
mother cried the day i was born because
she knew she would never be better than
me at any given moment i'm thinking
about one thing richard dreyfuss
hunkered over eating dog food i feel
like i'm the paris of people complete
overlap of ego and id it's been
theorized but i never thought i'd see it
i'm exquisite it's gina's phone leave me
a voicemail i won't check it cause it's
not 1993. uh you think you can just
bully people but you can't it's not okay
i'm the bully around here ask anyone
captain
turn your greatest weakness into your
greatest strength like paris hilton read
her sex tape i was born for politics i
have great hair and i love lying the
english language cannot fully capture
the depth and complexity of my thoughts
so i'm incorporating emoji into my
speech to better express myself
winky face every time you talk i hear
that sound that plays when pac-man dies
as everyone knows my spirit animal is
nature's greatest predator the wolf
but i committed a horrible sexual
blunder and i'm no longer wolf worthy
my spirit animal is now this
the naked mole rat
god's disgusting mistake let's go as
bone bros
i didn't strike you when you said
knocking boots but bone bros
i cannot abide
what precisely did you think your job
was ideally bull fighter but it's such a
boy's club this man is a timber lake and
you need to stop treating him like a
fatone
gina
[Music]
hey
somebody take her down catching a serial
killer to catching a serial killer to
rihanna because i love rihanna i hang
out in the men's room all the time
the acoustics are amazing
i'm taking an abnormal psych class and
everyone in it is obsessed with me i'm
gonna help you take these guys down
no you're not doing anything like that
you're not a cop i've watched what you
do for six years it's not that difficult
nypd you're under arrest
i would spend my five thousand dollars
to buy backstage passes to brittany and
then i'd ask her one question
you think you're better dancing than me
i'm scared of business man a whole army
of gray-suited brads and chads trying to
suck my soul and redeem it for frequent
flyer miles
you didn't think i'd put my actual hair
in a ponytail
are you insane i worked at a sunglass
kiosk at the mall for four years so not
only have i been through hell
i was assistant manager there
you are disturbingly good at this i grew
up forging report cards if people knew
how smart i was it would have been
harder to control them
young cheesy take the wheel
gina linetti is the real hero here but
isn't gina lynette more of a state of
mind like in a way we were all gina
linetti today i'm in the middle of a
feud with a that's not a knife guy from
crocodile dundee
he's being a real how was i
supposed to know there'd be consequences
for my actions the only thing i'm not
good at is modesty because i'm great at
it hey what are you doing in here whole
scanner was making me anxious so i came
in here to listen to some calming music
it's me singing the song i wrote
subway girl
getting all the looks holding onto your
big pile of books
one million people are living their
lives according to the gene amendments
they're like the ten commandments only
there's more and they're better i would
now like to express my gratitude the
best way i know how through song
gratitude
gratitude nothing bad ever happens to me
i have a crystal in my pocket at all
times what about when you got hit by
their bus that bus was going 60 miles
per hour and here i sit before you
completely fine and you want to say
crystals don't work okay no hard
feelings but i hate you not joking bye
anyway i didn't doubt myself for one
second i'm more confident now than i've
ever been i was only stalling because
there was a shipping delay with my
golden statue yeah that makes sense and
even though she looks like she has wet
hair and just combed through a deep
conditioning treatment and even though
her jeans look cheap and even though she
has sausage fingers i hope it reminds
you of me and i'm gonna miss you i'll
hold now for a five minute applause
break
do it
please
thank you thank you
thank you this feels right i love you
guys
[Music]
[Applause]
you